un veredicto que provocó ir a los
familiares de don t y wright la ex
agente de policía estadounidense
kimberly potter condenada por homicidio
involuntario fue sentenciada a dos años
de prisión
por la sentencia y la decisión de esta
corte es que usted será puesta bajo
custodia del comisionado de correcciones
por un período de 24 meses
deberá cumplir dos tercios de este
periodo estando 16 meses en prisión y un
tercio en libertad condicional asumiendo
que no se cometa ninguna ofensa
disciplinaria o violación de libertad
condicional kerr y wright la madre del
joven que murió en manos de la ex agente
de policía criticó el veredicto ya que
había pedido la sentencia más severa
posible que no
kim poder asesinó a mi hijo él murió del
11 de abril hoy el sistema de justicia
lo asesinó de nuevo me senté allí a
mirar con mi corazón adolorido
el watch
hice mi declaración de impacto de la
víctima que me llevo tanto tiempo
escribir y la red escribí una y otra vez
para no obtener una respuesta del juez
en absoluto
el 11 de abril de 2021 donde wright de
20 años fue detenido por kim potter en
los suburbios de la ciudad de mineápolis
por llevar un ambientador colgando
ilegalmente del espejo retrovisor de su
automóvil y la ficha de registro del
vehículo estaba vencida donde tenía
además una orden de arresto por porte
ilegal de armas el joven trató de huir y
poder disparo con su arma de servicio
que asegura haber confundido con su
pistola eléctrica el caso conmovió a
todo eeuu además fue el mismo día en que
se realizó el juicio contra el ex
policía directo bing que en mayo de 2020
asfixió con su rodilla a la
estadounidense george cloud lo que
desató una ola de manifestaciones en
varias partes del mundo